China remains probably the only large
country in the world still sticking to a
zero covet approach to the coronavirus
pandemic for its citizens that has meant
never-ending restrictions lockdowns and
regular State mandated testing and the
signs are this will continue for some
time especially given an upcoming
Communist Party Congress by President Xi
Jinping is expected to assume a historic
third term in power authorities want to
leave nothing to chance and that is a
tempner for many ahead of a week of
national holidays that begins on
Saturday
passenger numbers here paint a gloomy
picture of domestic travel and this
flight's headed to one of China's top
tourist destinations
upon arrival The Familiar site of people
dressed in hazmat suits are standing by
to swab you
this is the city of yanan in Northern
shansi Province it's Fame for being a
wartime stronghold for the Communists
during the Chinese Civil War a must
visit for party faithfuls but its status
as a red tourism hotspot hasn't shielded
it from the effects of covid-19 travel
curbs
is a folk singer and like many people
from yanan relies on travelers to make
ends meet
visitors from all over the country have
declined so our income has also Fallen
especially for artists like us life is
extremely hard Nan says she hopes
visitor numbers will pick up over
China's national golden week holidays
it's a peak seven-day holiday period
marking the founding of modern day China
but the pandemic has hit hard over the
last few years
one resident we spoke to called Wang
jihua said it was impossible not to
notice the change
three years ago tons of people would
come here from all over the country and
even from abroad to see this historic
site since the pandemic traffic has
decreased dramatically
tourists don't like to wear masks and
they don't like the idea of maybe not
being able to go home if there's a
lockdown
ahead of China's twice a decade
Communist Party Congress though
authorities are tightening restrictions
even further
the country's leadership is set for a
shake-up and president XI who's expected
to secure a precedent-breaking third
term has doubled down on China's zero
covert approach to ensure stability
from lockdowns to constant testing
there's plenty of fatigue anger even
overcover restrictions but people don't
like to talk about it openly earlier the
Sierra authorities warned they take
action against any criticism over the
country's covert policies
still there are plenty of signs of
people cracking this covert testing
Booth was spotted recently sprayed with
graffiti saying Give Me Freedom or give
me death
in this video circulating Chinese social
media a man gets set off when security
tell him to mask up while he's sitting
alone in his own restaurant
Joe Mesa is a senior Analyst at research
firm Trivium China he says people
looking for a quick relaxation of covert
curbs after Congress are likely to be
disappointed the main concern here is
about medical resources right
um the government is very concerned that
if it were to abandon Cove at zero you
would certainly have an overwhelming of
hospitals not in the medical resources
to go around what we may see is after
she is firmly enscoused in his third
term and in one sort of the political
aspect has sort of been squared away
there may be some additional room for
policy experimentation first on a small
scale and then if it proves accessible
on a larger scale it couldn't come soon
enough for places like yanan Nationwide
tourism fell by 28 in the first half of
this year compared to 2021 according to
China's tourism Ministry many people's
livelihoods here depend on a turnaround
happening sooner rather than later
let's get more on this from Poland Wang
in our East Asia Bureau in Taipei which
also reports on China Bowen why is China
still sticking to its core with zero
approach where nearly every other
country has learned to live with the
virus
well we can say that the reason why
China today is still sticking to its
Kobe zero policy it's because of the
political prestigious because China
where the first outbreak was registered
has always wanted to show the world that
he can control the pandemic better than
other countries for the Chinese
governments from Chinese Chinese
government's perspective the zero covet
lockdown strategy has been successful by
some metrics overall China has been able
to keep cases and deaths low compared
with many countries including you the US
and the Chinese government has made that
a point of Pride but now they are paying
the price for the policy however we can
also assume that if um Kobe restrictions
are loosened China will you know see a
potential uptick in cases hospital will
be flooded with the patients and the
whole medical system May face a
breakdown and the low vaccination rates
among the elderly in one medical reason
Chinese Authority used to justify that
ongoing Disease Control measures
now does this mean that China will
continue to stick to this policy even
after the Communist Party Congress in
mid-october
yeah so far we don't see any you know
concrete timeline for easing Kobe zero
policy in China however we do hear
people suggest that the government
should consider it comprehensively on
Sunday Chinese and commentator hu XI Jin
said that you know as China pounded its
coveted 19 policies epidemic experts
need to speak out and the government
should conduct comprehensive research
and make any study transparent to the
public he said the government should
tell people what are the pros and cons
of the policy for ordinary people and
for the whole country usually
anti-government messages on social media
platform will be censored but this time
it didn't and many netizens joined the
conversation and hope the government to
do something so we think under the you
know the pressure the public from the
public Chinese government will do
something
what is all this meant for the people in
this country I mean the the covet zero
policy
um
so Chinese government explained that
because the low rate vaccination rates
of elderly people mostly you know above
the age of 60 and because they they're
not they're more like a constitute a
conservative group of people so they
don't want to you know
um get the vaccine and that's why they
are the Potential Threat for the country
because if they the if they got infected
then it will cause a like a breakdown
for the medical system how is the covet
zero policy impacting people's everyday
lives Bowen
so as we saw that in the report in Yen
on with the golden week holidays start
starting on you know October 1st some
analysts predict there will be a drop in
tourist numbers and it may hurt the
terrorism industry as well however you
know like Chinese cities including
Beijing Shanghai Nanjing and Xi'an have
advised the residents to stay put as
their coming national holidays they use
this as approach to reduce the risk of
spreading in epidemic and flowing UPS
across the country and experts have also
noted that the residents should remain
cautious as a country still faces
pressure to curb the virus and
previously we saw a lot of people you
know their livelihoods have been
impacted by the the lockdown previously
like there are some tragedy happened on
social media platform like a bus
transporting residence to to a covet
quarantine facility has crashed and yeah
killing like
sorry it's a terrible tragedy upon
knowing in Taipei thank you so much for
joining us today